a Florida woman is facing manslaughter
and assault charges after a very
disturbing shooting that's leading to
new questions about the state's stand
your ground law AJ Owens is the woman
you're seeing on your screen right now
was shot and killed allegedly by a
neighbor through an apartment door in
front of one of her four children Mark
strausser reports it took four days for
charges to be filed in this case
a neighborhood Feud ended in tragedy
when achecka Owens was shot and killed
in front of her son Friday in Ocala
Florida
the 35 year old was struck in the upper
chest by a bullet shot through the front
door from a gun allegedly belonging to
58-year-old Susan Lawrence I wish our
shooter would have called us instead of
taking actions into her own hands but on
Friday night after owens's children were
playing outside and approached Lawrence
about an iPad they left Behind law
enforcement says Lorenz yelled at the
kids and threw a roller skate at them
leading Owens to confront Lawrence at
her door police say Lorenz pulled the
trigger shooting and killing the mother
of four she claimed self-defense under
Florida's stand your ground law which
gained national attention and spread to
other states after the killing of
Trayvon Martin more than a decade ago
the law authorizes the use of deadly
force for home protection if someone
believes it's necessary to prevent
imminent death or great bodily harm to
himself or herself we want to assure
that we get the facts right especially
in case to this level police opened up
an investigation but waited four days to
charge the shooter
the delay in arrest sparking protests
throughout the community attorneys for
the victims family issued a statement
following Tuesday's arrest saying
they're relieved but they are no less
concerned that accountability has taken
this long because archaic laws like
stand your ground exist she had no
weapons
she posed no imminent threat to anyone
what I'm asking is for justice
Justice for my daughter I'm Mark
Strassman for CBS mornings
I'd like to hear more about that case I
don't know how it's stand your ground
and you feel safe defend you're claiming
self-defense and bodily harm when you're
shooting through the door yeah there's a
lot of questions for me in that
particular case you know hopefully we'll
find out more information about